Dragon Ball Heroes is my religion this
beaver dream masterpiece might appear to
the untrained eye as yet more useless
schlock churned out of Akira Toriyama's
twenty 30 year old tennis shoes assuming
he plays tennis so I guess he doesn't so
it's turned out of his 30 year old
sweaty manga coach shoes got him all
right look what to hell with the
curatorial he didn't have anything to do
with Dragon Ball Heroes I'm sure I'll
find something for you to do later in
the video you go who's a good Toriyama
sensei you are yeah you are okay alright
so some of you out there might be
wondering where God's gift to mankind
the greatest big in the history of
anything ever Dragon Ball Heroes came
from well to give you a brief rundown
you know arcades know well they were
these buildings that were everywhere
back in the day filled with gaming
machines and other such activities kind
of like bowling but over the last couple
of decades they have become increasingly
more scarce with the advent of the
gaming console because no one wants to
go outside to get their games
well except Japan not only are arcades
still around in Japan but they are
[ __ ] everywhere taking up multiple
floors of numerous street corners
looking for a manga store nope arcade
looking for a cafe nope arcade looking
for a bathroom nope
[ __ ] arcade these places are insanely
popular and bring in so much business
that sometimes games developers create
games exclusively for these places they
don't get a way to release on console or
anything it's literally just this I have
no idea how they managed to do this oh
also this is sort of an aside to what I
was saying but last year I spent two
months living in Japan and to this day I
have no earthly idea how business works
in that country I was walking around
this tiny Street seemingly hidden away
from the rest of the world and squashed
in this tiny Street was my kid you not
and exclusively Allyson
and themed store that sold you guessed
it Alice in Wonderland stuff I peeked my
head inside the door and there was like
40 people crammed into this tiny
building scrambling to buy things Japan
I'll never understand you
but then in 2010 thanks Wikipedia Dragon
Ball Heroes the card game the video game
the arcade game was released and I kid
you not this came made
hella Bank by the end of 2016 the game
had sold over 500 million cards sold
separately in toy stores and made over
50 million yen that's a lot of yen you
actually place cards you buy at a store
on top of this machine in front of you
it's sort of like yugioh only way more
nerdy and I know this because I watched
a [ __ ] YouTube video explaining this
[ __ ] to me because eh
I'm too old and didn't have the first
[ __ ] idea what this [ __ ] even was and
B it's only available in Japan but I
hear you clamoring how did everyone in
America and not America learn about duck
I mean dragged Dragon Ball here that's
what I miss Dragon Ball Heroes and
that's easy
cutscenes [ __ ] hours of this [ __ ] all
with the same droning insufferably
catchy theme music it feels like it
loops every 15 seconds
and that [ __ ] gets top team concise your
head
I wrote this video last week and I'm
still humming it oh and speaking of
cutscenes on the first page of YouTube
search results alone Dragon Ball Heroes
cutscenes have amassed I know I wish it
was kidding
over 71 million views as of writing this
video that's almost twice the views of
the battle of gods movie that exists on
YouTube somehow for free good to know my
career depends on this flimsy copyright
ID system and that movie exists is
entirety there and a good defense for
that is well maybe they haven't had a
chance to take it down yet but then you
realize that it's been there for three
[ __ ] years but I'm not bitter whose
thing I'm bitter you [ __ ] off Akira
Toriyama but yes there are hours worth
of these cutscenes online floating
around with millions of views and all of
these cutscenes were animated or at
least corrected by tadayoshi Mamoru who
was the series director on Dragon Ball
super and once that show came to an end
and people realized he wasn't returning
on the upcoming movie people were asking
what he was going to be up to time
passed by and people were confused until
the day it was announced Dragon Ball
Heroes the card came the video game the
arcade game otherwise known as super
Dragon Ball heroes in May of 2018 it was
announced that a Dragon Ball Heroes
anime was in the works and in June one
month later a trailer dropped featuring
old characters and new clothes new
characters and weird clothes and that
[ __ ] song again the confusing thing
about this dome was that due to the fact
a large portion of the viewers for this
trailer were from the Western Hemisphere
they had no [ __ ] idea what this was
was it a movie was it for a game super
just ended is this the continuation of
the story and the short answer to all of
those was no the long answer no in
reality though it turned out to be
something unlike I had ever seen before
you guys have heard of promotional manga
right well this was a promotional anime
specifically promoting the Dragon Ball
Heroes arcade game and no I'm not
kidding
for God's sake Yama more oh you've done
stuff like this
what happened well you're gonna find out
because you bet your sweet nipples I'm
gonna go through every episode released
since the first episodes release on July
1st what but it's October you telling me
there's only been four episodes man okay
let's jump into it
July first episode one dog okay so the
rundown of the show in a nutshell is
it's 100% not part of the main cannon
story of Dragonball it sort of floats
somewhere in between
dokkan battle and that show that shall
not be named I know epic right so this
episode begins exactly like every other
scene that would begin with Goku Vegeta
and wheezes the focus yeah we Spotty's
the two of them easily because of course
he does and that's when the first weird
thing happens by arrives I have several
questions why is she here how did she
get to this time how did she get to lord
beerus his plan why would she even
things to go there why does Goku respond
to it like it's no big deal oh my it
turns out that trunks was supposed to be
coming here for training why wouldn't he
train with himself or with the gods in
his timeline you see I've already made
the first mistake of watching super
Dragon Ball heroes thinking you're not
supposed to think when you watch this
show
why does Goku react so casually why does
my trust this purple person who is so
evil it hurts how does he know how to
teleport these are all questions you
don't have to ask if you don't think and
if you don't think it's awesome
so I'll be a super bad guy seriously
though just look at him foo he's out
asking them to follow him to the prison
planet where trunks is being held
captive yeah I know but look it gets
worse this so-called prison planet man
it's a it's literally a bunch of planets
just chained together complete with what
looks like Saturn I'm not even
well-versed in science and my brain
hurts just looking at that
I wonder who has the mark you thinking
again stop it look at the pretty colors
so we aren't on the planet five seconds
and this Goku shows up yeah I don't know
either but believe you me it gets
weirder the following is a TM public
service announcement now we don't speak
about that show on this channel for
reasons that should be abundantly quick
what do you mean it's not clear it
should be what would you did you meet
Toriyama sensei cry honestly but yeah
this go could go super saiyan for
lunging at our Goku I mean I think it's
our Goku it or is it a different
timeline
anyways they fight for all of one minute
before stopping to take notice of fou
you know that obviously evil purple dude
with the the cliche anime glasses thing
yeah him well he makes noises with his
mouth for a while explaining that he was
behind all of this bla bla bla bla bla
it doesn't really matter forey Goku's
part of the time patrol who made this
planet yada yada yada
that sort of stuff food use trunks as
bait to lure goku vegeta to said planet
oh by the way you think it might have
been over the course of a 20-minute
episode perhaps even two episodes
it is Dragonball after all well it
didn't this whole exposition dump goku
and vegeta training meeting my
embarrasses world and the fight with
Super Saiyan Goku on top of the prison
planet all takes place in five minutes
yeah I don't think I've gotten whiplash
from watching a TV show before but this
is close
finally evil man machete bad guy foo
cuts to the chase having spent two of
the first five minutes rambling about
what's going on he explains that they
need to collect seven Dragon Balls yeah
they start with wood and need to take
the remaining six balls from six
individual prisoners all the while I
tried to resist the urge of making and
grabbing the balls of prisoners joke and
that's pretty much the first episode oh
hey look it's cooler okay so let's hop
into episode two [ __ ] this song the
episode starts with evil Saiyan man
catching up with Vegeta and Goku who
have decided that walking around is the
best way of travelling in this urgent
situation I guess they're walking
because my is there but they can carry
her
why don't they fly I don't know I don't
know evil saying man shows up to fight
in a body restraint so that's the thing
Goku goes to punch him not the furry one
but the evil sayings but black aura two
touches Goku and turns him evil for the
first couple minutes huh mark you're
thinking again stop it hey look it's
color we learned that this new stain is
called cumber and apparently anyone he
touches turns evil so more talking
happens and cooler goes golden because
of course he does he punches evil Goku
literally once and charges up a blast in
that form you would think it would
destroy both Goku
the prison planet but it doesn't it
kicks up some dust and knocks Goku down
a bit he's suddenly not evil anymore and
perfectly fine but let's not think about
that because there's still so much to
see
Cobra breaks out of his restraints and
mitosis Goku Vegeta the potaro sheep has
in her pocket for summary don't question
it
because if you question it that means
you're thinking hey look it's vegeto so
that was episode two so some things
happen and some fighting happened let's
dig further I'm not sick of watching it
you're sick of watching it shut up
Toriyama relax Mac it's it's getting to
you okay so episode three has the best
start to any Dragonball anything I've
ever seen maybe the best intro to
anything I've seen in the history of
anything ever let's break it down
so Vegeta is standing there looking all
cross staring directly at comber choking
trunks who's literally screaming vegeto
stays in that pose looking directly at
cumber while he continues to choke
trunks this goes on for almost a full
minute I'm not kidding
it's amazing what happens after that
shot though is sort of for I mean this
is the best show ever and I love
watching cooler just stand there having
thrown literally one punch in the entire
show so far oh hey look Kaioken trunks
at this time is limping away with the
help of my I guess that choke converted
really did a number on his legs
I don't know so the evil say encumber
pulls Vegeta and throws that big
thoughts wave thing ball into the air
and continues to turn into a Super
Saiyan great ape launching a blast of
Aegina resulting in them splitting into
again their time limit after running out
whatever will our heroes do find out
right now
so episode 4 begins and wouldn't you
know it cooler is still standing around
doing nothing but hey why can apparently
[ __ ] Patara earring so we won't be shown
of any fusions in the future and Jesus
Christ wouldn't you know it I spoke too
soon coolers actually doing something
sort of foo apparently is getting really
upset too because the chains are
knocking around the fighters I'm gonna
be honest though I'm not entirely
certain I know what exactly those chains
are for or even what foo wants besides
the opportunity to conduct this
experiment so yeah to stop all of this
senseless chaos and to protect his
precious chains which are important for
some reason foo destroys cumbers energy
ball moon thing and slashes at him for
good measure
causing comfort to revert back down to
his regular size yep that's it the
release schedule for these day is sort
of irregular the time between episodes 1
& 2 was a little over two weeks while
the gap between episodes 2 & 3 was
almost 2 months so that's not exactly
much of a routine you can get into while
watching these but you can always do
what I did and just binge them in like
half an hour the total run time of the
four episodes excluding the Opie's is
around that do I think it's any good
honestly it makes my head hurt if I
think too much about it but as a dumb
bit of harmless dragon ball fun it's
totally serviceable it doesn't really do
anything special and for me if I was to
look at it objectively it focuses too
much and almost exclusively on the
things that people outside of the anime
bubble consider Dragon Ball to be about
random transformations nonsensical
fights utter chaos narrative Lee
speaking and believe it or not that's
one thing that this men tried to shy
away from in writing interesting stories
with these characters these kinds of
chaotic moments might be what Dragonball
is remembered for but they are not what
made the series good or great with that
said I think super Dragon Ball Heroes is
a good idea to appease that area of the
viewership that wants that sort of
mindless stuff and does its job very
well than promoting the game it's
created for despite it having a theme
that I want to erase from my brain but
what do you guys think let me know in
the comments down below
I've been torn up mark thank you so much
for watching